Are you ready for the surprise?
I don't know. It's a big one.
I'm afraid. Don't be afraid.
You're joking. Oh my God.
This is your grandson. Phoenix Barron Hilton
Reem. Are you
Serious? Yeah.
Paris, are you serious?
Oh my god.
Oh My God.
are you serious? Yeah.
Ooh what is it baby.
Oh my goodness.
Oh, honey.
Oh my God.
This is your grandma.
This is Kiki.
Is this real?
Yeah, it's my son.
I just feel like my whole life has been so
public, and I just didn't want to have the
media and people talking about my son before
he was born and I'm sorry I didn't tell you
before, but this is my baby.
He's such a good baby.
He doesn't cry.
I love you.
I love.
Oh. You like his name?
I didn't hear it again. What is it?
Phoenix Baron Hilton Reme.
Oh his voice.
He's such a good baby.
Let me see you, angel.
He's so gorgeous.
I cannot believe it.
Paris. This is the most special, most
exciting thing in life.
I'm so happy. Your whole life is going to
change. I know, because this is what
matters. I know.
Paris and I, our relationship, the peaks and
valleys and some of the valleys were very
deep. And dark.
And I never could imagine that we would be
where we are today.
I'm on the other side of the mountain and
I'm so grateful. Has Nikki
seen anything?
No one. No one knows about him.
The world doesn't know about him.
Nikki doesn't know.
Should we call her on FaceTime?
Dad's got to know first.
No one knows. Literally.
Your father. You're the only person who.
Carter's family doesn't know.
I just can't even believe it. Look at this.
Oh my goodness.
He's the sweetest baby.
He's got the longest hands.
Oh my God, look at those hands.
Wait. Nick. Paris.
Is that a is that his thumb?
That's a long thumb. Is it?
Wait, is that his thumb?
Oh, no.
Oh, is the thumb there?
One. Two. Three. Four.
Okay. Wait.
What?
No, that's the pointer finger.
It is. Thought it was his thumb.
I'm thinking that is Paris.
I've never seen his hands as big as his
face. Oh my God, Paris!
Was I a cute baby when I was born?
Beautiful.
And not all babies are.
I was so scared when he came out.
I was like, oh, I hope it's because some
babies are just like. They look like scary
aliens. But he was just like, perfect.
Look. He's fresh.
Are you fresh?
You're fresh.
I just can't get over him.
My mom was over the moon.
And I'm relieved because she doesn't really
show emotions like that.
I feel so corny, and Carter is so sweet with
him.
I said. Such a cute dad.
He's so proud.
Do you have him on a schedule?
Yes.
He eats every three hours.
We have an incredible nanny.
We love her. Gina.
She's amazing.
She's really sweet.
She's so attentive and so grateful for her.
I was on my zooms, but I heard you guys were
meeting Phoenix, so I figured..
I have
Never in my life.
He is perfect.
Look at him.
He's so cute.
You're fresh.
Boop boop be doop.
I'm experiencing one of the most surreal
moments, probably, I will ever experience.